مع اقتراب موسم الشتاء في العاصمه
السعوديه رياض يقبل الزوار والسائحون على
مناطق للتخييم تتناسب مع هذا الموسم حيث
تسمح الاجواء البارده هناك خلال فصل
الشتاء القيامه بمجموعه من الانشطه
الترفيهيه والرحلات حيث اصبحت اغلب
المخيمات جاهزه لاستقبال السائحين والزوار
العديد من المناطق الرمليه والمخيمات
الشتويه استعدادات لموسم الشتاء عبر مناطق
مجهزه بكافه احتياجات الزوار الراغبين
بعيش تجربه شتويه مميزه من خلال الرحلات
الشتويه التي تعتبر من اهم فعاليات موسم
الشتاء حيث تهيا لهذه المناطق الرياضيه
والشواء والالعاب
[موسيقى]
من رياض الجنه
همم لا لا لا لا مالك مالك مالك مالك
اليوم نعم تجربه جميله جدا في الرياض
الحين اتكلم اليوم سهام عن احدى اهم تجارب
الشتاء اليوم في الرياض ركوب الدبابات
رياضه الهايكنج عدد كبير جدا ايضا من
الفعاليات اليوم احنا نتكلم عن موسم جميل
جدا في الرياض هو موسم الشتاء هذا الموسم
الذي همم يعني كل كل متولع فيه الفتره هذه
والكل ينتظر هذا الفصل همم
بكافه الوسائل طبعا احنا نتكلم عن منطقه
ايضا سهام مليئه بالمناطق الرمليه الكثيفه
مليئه ايضا بالفعاليات مليئه ايضا
بالرحلات الكبيره جدا نشاهد هذه المنطقه
التي تحوي عدد من المناطق مناطق الالعاب
ايضا همم مناطق الشواء مناطق ايضا التخييم
حتى منطقه بمتابعه كاس العالم يعني كاس
العالم ورانا في كل مكان حتى في البر طيب
نتحدث اكثر اليوم عن ما هي الرحلات التي
تنظم في البرق خلال هذه الايام ايضا ما هي
الفعاليات التي يتم تنظيمها يسعدنا ويكون
معي الانستاذ محمد جميل وهو منظم من حيث
السياحيه او نرحب فيك معانا على الصباح
العربيه كل من الاستاذ محمد اليوم ابرز
الفعاليات الموجوده في شتاء الرياض اهلا
وسهلا صباح الخير على الجميع همم احنا
صراحه همم يهمنا راي العميل قبل كل شيء
فعلشان نوصل لترغيب ناجح للعميل ترغيب هو
معادله حراميه لازم تكون متكام
فتعدد الخيارات السلام الامان سهوله
الوصول التكرار المستمر بشكل ناجح هي اهم
عوامل
الترغيب الناجح يعني ففي عندنا الفعاليات
البريه المختلفه كانت الدبابات تزلج على
الرمل المشي على الرمل
الجلسات الخارجيه والداخليه النار
همم
[موسيقى]
الاختلاف هذا والتعدد
ويعطي ترغيب ناجح يعني طيب حدث اليوم يعني
احنا نتكلم عن منطقه رمليه مليئه
بالفعاليه ومناطق التخييم مناطق الشواء
شيء اكثر فعاليه الناس تحبها اليوم في
الرياض يعني خصوصا انك انت منظم رحاله
السياحيه وعارفين جو الناس ايش اكثر شيء
الناس تحب اليوم في الرياض والله شوف يعني
ما شاء الله تبارك الرياض صارت متعدده
الخيارات الترفيهيه والسياحيه وكمان مناطق
زيارات متعدده بشكل كبير جدا لكن احنا
عندنا هنا كمان ضمير رحلات بريه سياحيه
لاحظنا بشكل كبير في طلب كبير جدا على
المشي ان كان في اعلى مناطق رمليه او كم
مناطق جبليه طيب اليوم احنا اتكلم عن هذه
المناطق هي منطقه همم
حولها عدد كبير جدا من المناطق قد ايش هي
فتره الذروه للناس تحب تجيء فيها تكشف
فيها تاخذ جوها وتستاند وتنبسط تستانس شيل
الفترات اللي لا الناس كده تشوفهم يعني
بالمئات في هذا المكان كلنا ضروري كده
ضروره الرحلات والكشتات في الويكند فالناس
تطلع من جو العمل وضغط العمل وضغط يعني
الضغوطات الخارجيه تنتظر الويكند بشكل
كبير فعشان كده احنا دائما نركز انه احنا
نبرز فعاليات وخدماتنا في الويكند ان كان
خميس او جمعه او سبت طيب انا اليوم يعني
بكل امانه شايف ما شاء الله يعني مناطق
التخييم العاديه سهام مناطق فيها مناطق
جلسات شعبيه همم ايضا مناطق ترفيهيه لكن
اليوم حنا نشوف مناطق حتى لالعاب الاطفال
ومناطق الالعاب الكرنفاليه حاكيني عنها
وكيف استعددتهم هذه الفكره اليوم في
مخيمكم احنا ركزنا بشكل كبير ان احنا نكسر
يعني بروتين الممل لانه همم الاستمراريه
تتواجد العلماء قدي يصيبه نوع من انواع
الملل انه كل جمعه نفس الفعاليات نفس كل
شيء احنا قاعدين نغير من فعالياتنا بشكل
الاسبوع نظيف خدمات على المخيم نظيف
عاليات او حتى شيء جديد في المخيم العاب
الكربلائيه استخدمنا فيها فئات عمريه
مختلفه للكبار والصغار في الكوخ الخشبي
هذا متخصص للاطفال كالعاب رمليه يشرف
عليهم معلمه مشرفه متخصصه لتعليم الاطفال
تكون معاهم على مدار الوقت كامل خلال
الرحله طيب انت اليوم ما شاء الله منظم
رحلات سياحيه لك سنوات كبيره في المجال
ايش تنصح الناس اليوم حابه تيجي للرياضيات
والشتاء الرياض وتعيش هذه التجربه ايش
تنصحهم فيه سواء على المستوى التجارب اللي
يعيشوها او حتى على المستوى الامن
والسلامه
قبل كل شيء ااا اذا انت طالع رحله بري او
اي مكان دائما خذ معك احتياطاتك الان
الاجواء في مرحله تغيير فاقد معك احتياطات
لكن كان الجو امطار او هواء شديد خليه معك
احتياطات اصحاب الامراض المزمنه خلي معك
علاجاتك وقبل كل شيء اطلع من البيت
اطلع وتمشى وغير جو الرياض ومده المملكه
كلها تحت دعم كبير جدا من الهيئه السعوديه
للسياحه باشراف قوي من وزاره السياحه
فيها خيرات سياحيه وترفيهيه كبيره جدا
شكرا لك استاذ محمد سعيد ذيك اليوم في
صباح العربيه اذا سهام هذه التجربه
المثاليه هذه التجربه الجميله التي
بالتاكيد انها تجربه اثريه تجربه مدهشه
انا بصراحه يعني مبسوط جدا واتمنى اتمنى
انه كل فريق صباح العربي وكل فريق العربيه
يعيشون هذه الاجواء ايضا احنا امام فصل
وموسم جميل ومليء بالمغامرات مليء
بالتجاره
طب الاقبال على هذه المخيمات الشتويه انت
موجود هناك كيف هو يا اسامه
بصراحه انا عملت استقصاء بسيط جدا حول هذا
الموضوع انه تقريبا من نهايه الشهر الجاري
بدايه فصل الشتاء الفعلي في الرياض سوف
يكون هناك اقبال كبير جدا حدثنا ايضا
الاستاذ محمد انه ب 300 الى 400 شخص يكون
في فتره نهايه الاسبوع واجازه نهايه
الاسبوع في هذه المناطق لاعيش هذه التجربه
الجميع طبعا هذه المناطق غالبا قوتها
وجمالها همم في فصل الشتاء لانه الاجواء
بارده وبتعرفين ايضا الصحراء والبر يعطي
نوع من الرياحيه والوناسه تقريبا هذه
الفتره الويكند بينما ال- مع دخول فصل
الشتاء الفعلي هيكون في في اقبال كبير جدا
معروف ايضا انه الثمامه كامل مناطقها
وبكامل همم محطاتها الرمليه ايضا همم
مغريه جدا همم وانها تجيب تستقبل العدد
كبير جدا من الاشخاص سواء من داخل الرياض
او من خارج الرياض او حتى من خارج
السعوديه الاجانب بالمناسبه لما نيجي
السعوديه
ايدي في تفكيرهم ان هم لازم يعيشوا تجربه
انهم يجيئوا البر وكذا ناجي اجانب كثير
جدا في هذه المنطقه عشان تجربه البر
ومستغربين انه في بر وجو بارد او حتى جو
معتدل بنظرهم لكن التاكيد هذه الرياضه
وهذه فتنه الرياضه وهذه فتنه السعوديه
كلها يعني فكل امانه المناطق جدا جميله
ورائعه واتمنى لو انه يعني يتم ايضا
زيارتها بشكل اوسع شكرا جزيلا اسامه
القاسم صباح العربيه من الرياض شكرا لك
اسامه